[Music]
well thirty year old Michael Rotondo
lived in his parents basement for eight
years rent-free as parents kept asking
him to leave they asked five times they
gave him a thousand bucks to help him
find a new place but he did not take the
hint
so finally his parents went to court now
a judge has ordered Rotondo to leave the
boy man-child claims he shouldn't have
to leave because he doesn't want to
leave watch I'm not a burden to them in
the home they don't provide laundry or
food it's it's really a moot point
for them to seek me to be objective
Kathy aru is the founding publisher of
Catalina magazine we were interested to
know what she thought of mr. Rotondo she
joins us tonight so Kathy he's 30 years
old but he says he doesn't want to leave
right he'd be forced to leave but why I
mean a third of 18 to 35 year olds in
this country live with their parents so
he's actually normal and Michael loves
his mom he wants to be with his mom
what's so wrong with that he loves his
parents so he's normal and he wants to
be with his parents at a time when he's
not ready to move on so you would think
if parents would welcome him there his
mom would want to be a good mom and have
her son lived there they don't sound
like grateful parents so no age of 30
you're not ready to leave your mom's
basement why are you ready to vote or
drive a car or drink alcohol or serve in
uniform well we don't know if he does
any of those things
but we do know that he's not ready to
leave his mom's and he's not his
basement he has a bedroom he said
clearly he doesn't live in the basement
so I'm sorry sorry to disturb what's
wrong with loving your mother and in the
future maybe she will want to live in
his bedroom in his house when he's more
adjusted and feels better and is
prepared for the world maybe Michael
will have a nice house maybe a mansion
thanks to their support that they
wouldn't spend that money on the lawyers
but they'll actually spend it on him and
his future on their son nothing I'm
gonna tell you look I'm trying as always
I'm trying to discern a theme here that
I can apply to other parts of my life
okay if you love something you get it
for free which I understand so if I love
I don't know a Rolex watch do I get it
for free I mean if I really love
but we really love it this is a parent
and a child if you're a parent you're
always a parent so if she's a mom she's
always a mom if there's in the son he's
always a son so they should always love
each other they should hire lawyers and
go against each other in court as the
mother did well I agree I totally agree
but what if I love the watch and I need
to know what time it is because
otherwise you get law you need to know
what time it is okay and I love that
watch it's a sincere love why would they
call the cops of me if I just take it
it's about responsibility she gave birth
to this child
you didn't give birth to that watch so
no it's true yes so it's very different
so this mother should understand she
gave birth to this child it's her
responsibility it's good for society for
her to take care of this child her child
no matter how old this child is and make
sure her child is ready to face the
world sure there's no you can't age out
of this arrangement once you're born you
have a moral and I think legal right to
sponge off your parents forever I don't
think it's sponging off I think he loves
his mother
he looked Michael loves his mommy and he
wants to be with her until he's ready 20
seconds but are you concerned about the
profusion the explosion of man children
are in our society is that good for
women women and men 18 to 35 are living
at home with their parents a third of
Millennials are living at home with
their parents so this is what's
happening right now and we seem fine as
a society I mean it's make America great
again right we're great or a great
society mom when you're 30 is making
America great again
it's a sad brave new world that we
should resist at all costs but whatever
we disagree Kathy rue it is great to see
you as always thank you thank you